hey guys welcome to the Staples Center
we are here behind the scenes of a Bon
Jovi concert in Los Angeles they have
some insane technology there's never
been used for in a concert you're gonna
go check it out did I make that with
your Crayolas I did I got some sharpies
I was like I'm gonna make you this
really nice welcome to the Staples
Center
I'll bet you that took about 20 minutes
I'll give it on toric total February
March and this is it was the third
what's cool so not not so great no
that's red I'm like 35 shows into it so
I'm not I'm not cuckoo nobody here yet
but soon this entire plane filled the
Bon Jovi man
[Applause]
so what are the cool things other than
all of this craziness going on here they
have a Bon Jovi app that has augmented
reality check out augmented reality it
activates your camera yeah I did
point your phone at the Bon Jovi album
cover and watch it come to watch loading
and so to do that literally it's like
old-school animation and animation they
literally had to draw each frame to have
the guys walk out thank you for showing
you that thank you and thank you for the
awesome tour anytime really
this actually is valid for the entire
tour you pass so I've never taken stuff
at this point
who washes our clothes here just anybody
how do you guys get this stuff place a
place and there's so much we have 15
trucks one crew one stage after they
tear it down
they drive put it back up every not
every bolt accounted for all put onto
all these trucks how long does the setup
take six half hours
done we have riggers electricians
carpenters next time I move I know where
I'm going I'm gonna get the Bon Jovi
tour crew to move my apartment this is
great and now behind me are ten tour
busses that pretty much go everywhere I
mean there's so many people I think is
it just a 160 people ish I think they
should take me on tour hundred sixty one
you may have a drying room that's what
I'm trying to figure out what my job
could be elector then we'll be driving I
can't even parallel park my car do you
want to you want to talk to us please
introduce yourself to the Internet here
and I'm David Bergman on Bon Jovi's tour
photographer can you take photos of
everything you said you do billboards
magazines Plus show pretty much any
pictures you see of Bon Jovi out in the
world almost all of them are pretty much
mine anything officially from Bon Jovi
pretty much sure we take a little look
and see what else we got here
right now I am standing on top of these
hexes Bon Jovi will be standing on in
approximately two hours his feet will be
right with my feet are really
turn if they turn me off
they're like daughter this is Bon Jovi's
my Christmas and he's had some babies
they said that they take two of them on
tour I knew like four boards three
towards maybe two cordial a guitar so
this is the tuning room and he said I
could mess with some of the gear so of
course let's let's do it hold on no no
this one you know too close or too fast
three gels probably not going to be a
drummer anytime soon so let's put those
down there's three different rubber cams
and what they can do from back here is
everything that a man camera can do out
there I try it
oh it's move oh it's moving it okay
alright oh it's fine
John John Rory yeah where'd you go oh
okay it's focus oh it looks pretty good
oh wow this is really awesome
my focus is just impeccable its new
stuff you know not many tours are doing
us and I'll come back later and if you
guys you need help let me know okay all
right guys let's go right now we're
gonna head to server lands what is your
main job here we're responsible for
content management screens control and
what we do with this and you were
walking on it earlier those hexagons
columns all that projection that happens
to it is these machines right here
handle all that mapping and they
understand where the columns actually
are in real space and we we map on that
I see new cleats you Wow so here I do
lighting and he is running the video off
we have 48 lights that actually move up
and down the cable spools up into the
which with it so it actually looks like
the light is sort of floating now you've
got 10 projectors these are those giant
things 6 in the back so that the people
in the back of to see as well how do you
control all of that everything lighting
in videos consults about here we both
actually operate the same machinery the
grand ma q v lot of ceramic video
lighting it seems easy but it no it
doesn't actually seem Daisy at all what
are you talking about victus well it's
not in here
here's all of John's perfectly tuned
guitars and I was born to not touch
anything so this is me not touching
everything just kidding just get I
didn't touch
I didn't there's no touching